i don't know if you've read carl jung
said
that the greatest danger that humanity
faces is not from any external force
like natural disasters
or diseases or pandemics
he said the greatest danger that
humanity faces
is collective psychosis
so to some extent i see it happening
not quite as extreme yet as in
places like maoist china or cambodia
where
um one third of the population got
murdered in companies
absurd totally absurd ideas taking over
people's minds for example in cambodia
um we were there a few years ago
the at the time of pol pot the
cambodian mad dictator
um anybody who could uh
read and write or anybody if you wear
glasses you were an
enemy of the people because you were
regarded as the oppressor
and likely to be killed if you had to
show your hands and did you well
oh you're not doing manual work you're
one of you
you're one of the enemies of the people
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
one of the most widely recognized
spiritual teachers
on the planet his book the power of now
sold 12 million that's million copies
and the follow-up a new earth sold over
15 million copies
both have been translated in over 50
languages
my friend eckhart tolle welcome back to
the reuben report
thank you dave nice to see you again
it's great to talk to you uh as my
audience knows we are at the beginning
of august right now and i am technically
off the grid i am in an undisclosed
location with no
technology no phone no computer no
news no nothing so we're taping this at
the end of july and i thought you would
be the right person to
sort of kick this month off with uh so
before we get to sort of the off the
grid stuff
and and digital detox i wanted to ask
you just sort of what do you make of the
the spiritual health of the planet
in this last year and a half this sort
of crazy
year and a half that we've all had to
deal with
uh yes uh i believe crazy
is a quite good word to describe it in
many ways
there's been many collective challenges
the main one is the
virus and the lockdowns
uh and various other challenges
um i've had this strange feeling idea
in the past few months um
that a certain segment of humanity
is uh
losing the ability to think rationally
there is a decrease in whether
i call it iq or whatever it may be
there is a diminishment of rational
faculty
as reflected in many ways on
uh mainstream media social media and so
on
and another segment of humanity is
actually becoming more aware
more aware more conscious is not drawn
into the regressive
phase that some of humanity may be going
through
it's not unusual for humanity to
occasionally
collectively regress to a lower state of
consciousness it has happened
whenever a country or collective has
been taken over
by an almost one could say
toxic ideology that has completely
taken possession of millions of people's
minds
look at of course national national
socialism in germany
the maoist cultural revolution was quite
crazy what happened in cambodia under
pol pot
totally crazy ideas invaded
millions of people's minds and
reduced their ability to to actually
engage in
rational thinking and
things it happened for example in maoist
china during the cultural revolution
children reporting on their parents when
they were angry with their parents all
they had to do is go to school and
report their parents if they had said
something against the
government the parents would be taken
away never seen again
they they went around public parks in
big cities in china tearing out flowers
out of because beauty with regards as
bourgeois
you have to kill your back your pets
your your dogs and cats
totally and these are just a few
examples of
totally toxic and
irrational thoughts taking over people's
minds
so that's to some extent i've been
seeing this
happening collectively not just in one
country in quite a few western
many western countries that i'm aware of
and but it has not affected everybody
some people have managed to remain aware
they have not been
one could say infected by
what one could perhaps call a a mental
virus or mental viruses
that reduce people's ability
to actually see reality reality then
gets distorted through the veil
of these mental viruses that have taken
over people's minds
this is more serious
more serious pandemic than anything that
happens on the physical
level as far as um pandemics are
concerned the actual viruses
actually you might i don't know if
you've read
carl jung said that the greatest danger
that humanity faces is not from
any external force like natural
disasters
or diseases or pandemics
he said the greatest danger that
humanity faces
is collective psychosis
so to some extent i see it happening not
quite as
extreme yet as in places like mao as
china or cambodia where
um one third of the population got
murdered
absurd totally absurd ideas taking over
people's minds for example in cambodia
um we were there a few years ago
the at the time of pol pott the
cambodian mad dictator
um anybody who could uh
read and write or anybody if you wear
glasses you were an enemy of the people
because you were regarded as the
oppressor
and likely to be killed if you had to
show your hands and did you well
oh you're not doing manual work you're
one of you
you're one of the enemies of the people
that send them away got killed one third
or more of the population got
exterminated through
insanity taking over people's minds
um to some extra that you no longer can
see reality as it is the famous example
from
1984 or well um
you have to believe that two plus two
equals five
and uh if you don't believe it then you
are the you are the enemy
which is sort of what we're being told
these days from
uh some some pretty powerful people and
some pretty
powerful people that are pushing bad
ideas but i i suspect that you think if
more
people lived in the moment if more
people
harness the power of now that that would
be the best inoculation from this mind
virus
yes inoculation or
to have um
an inoculation is one word you could one
could use the key
is uh immunity i think i would use
immunity
the key is what we could call
awareness or i sometimes call it
presence awareness it says
awareness or presence is nothing
complicated or it's the ability
to become aware of your thoughts
uh so you can take a step back
and observe what thoughts are going
through your head
for example when this ability arises
i call that the beginning of a spiritual
awakening
spiritual is no longer being
completely trapped and identified with
the movement of thinking
this is particularly important now the
danger of
infection viral infection on a mental
level
has always been there but it's now
become inc
magnified by the technology that we now
have
a toxic idea a toxic thought
can spread like wildfire through the
internet
within a few days and can
take possession or become lodged
in countless people's minds and once a
thought is become
lodged then it will attract associated
thoughts that resonate with it
and then suddenly you see
reality through the veil of
of that irrational thinking but you
don't know that this is happening
because you do not have the immunity of
awareness
awareness is the ability to know what
your mind is doing
it's also for example the ability i
think it was aristotle who said
talked about the ability of having two
conflicting thoughts in your mind
without
necessarily identifying with either that
is
implies there is an awareness there
without awareness
one thought will draw you in completely
you will identify with completely
and then you everything else is then
disregarded
or regarded as uh threatening
the egoic self likes it identifies with
one particular position
and this is just one example there are
many similar examples one could give
it identifies with one position and then
everything else is regarded as
uh whatever the term is uh
what are the favorite terms these days
disinformation
or whatever anybody who disagrees with
my mental position that's disinformation
we're not an example of that so so
what's the best way
to immunize yourself against that i mean
i think about that all the time
i try uh to bring information to people
in as honest
and decent way as possible and sometimes
i think i'm pretty decent probably
sometimes not so decent
but i have no doubt that i have that
veil as well and i have
probable blind spots due to my history
or
whatever it might be how do you how do
you actually climb out of something
if you're if you're unaware of it at
some level yes to become aware of one's
thinking
there's no easy answer to that to many
people this happens naturally
for example it it tends to happen
sometimes to people
on a personal level whose thinking
becomes
so negative about the in other words the
stories they tell themselves
let's talk about narratives where people
have in them
in their heads in their minds my life is
so dreadful and
all all i've been treated so unfairly by
society and
life and i've had everything bad always
happens to me
i know these things because when i was
young i i had similar thoughts
in my mind very negative negative
narratives
and the more negative narratives you
have for some people it's
the negative narratives about the world
out there which is
everything is evil and they're out too
they're how to sabotage me and
and so on all the negative narrative may
be about myself there's something wrong
with me
whatever it may be it leads to an
enormous amount of suffering
emotional suffering because the emotion
is usually a reflection
of what you're telling yourself in your
mind
creates a reflex reflection on the
emotional level
so if your narrative is very negative
you feel you then experience very
negative emotions
anger sadness resentment
or in if uh if you're very if you
if your narrative is very much directly
towards the future
the fearful future then there's a lot of
anxiety and fear because the future is
so uncertain
and so people who go into a lot of
suffering at some point they sometimes
realize that the suffering they
experience
is actually produced by their own minds
for example somebody might suddenly wake
up and say
for the for the the past few hours i've
been engaged in negative thinking about
myself and the world
wow isn't that amazing and i have these
thoughts that could
that come back again they recur again
and again
thoughts about myself things i tell
myself about myself
and so these thoughts are creating so
much suffering
you can stand back and say well i'm so
negative
why am i always criticizing people why
am i always complaining about
everything this this is the beginning of
becoming aware of what's happening
complaining is a big pattern in many
people's minds
they love complaining complaining about
what's out there complaining of my life
and running about them
complaining and i'm not talking about
complaining
when where you have the ability to
change a situation then
sometimes it's good to speak out when
there's possibility of change but many
cases
people just complain because it makes
the ego feel bigger because the more i
complain about
others the more the bigger my ego feels
because i'm right and they are all wrong
and it has to be right
you're you're perfectly spelling out uh
exactly why i get off social media
because we all suffer we all suffer from
that if i get a lot of retweets it has a
certain
dopamine effect to me or all right
sometimes i open it up and i'll look for
negative comments even though i don't
consider myself
a negative person yes now but the very
important thing when you have
interviews or dialogues with people
there's usually
a there's a background field of
a peaceful coming together there's a
background field of
there's a certain connection even if
what your opinion and the person you're
interviewing maybe
a very different viewpoints very
different thoughts
nevertheless you're not so identified
with the viewpoint
the mental position that
any body who questions your viewpoint
is unconsciously regarded as an enemy
that needs to be defeated
so that you have an awareness perhaps
you don't call it awareness
when you when you haven't when you
conduct interviews
there's still an under a background
field of
peace there is not antagonism
i observed the same i was very happy to
observe
um
russell brandt recently interviewed
um
[Music]
ben shapiro and there was a lot of
disagreement but but there was a mutual
completely different positions russell
wright is on the left obviously
beerus on the right and then they
reversed it later ben shapiro
had him on his show and it was very
really very pleasant to watch they were
both able to
express clearly their viewpoints and
their mental positions
without attacking each other at all so
there was an
undercurrent of awareness
as i would call it which is a which is
it is a dimension of consciousness that
is extremely important
for humans to uh to realize within
themselves because if you
if you're not aware of what your mind is
doing
so there's some separation from the
mental position which is the thought
and who you are who you are
is the aware presence in the background
that frees you from being possessed
by thoughts by narratives based by
mental positions and so it takes the ego
out of the interaction and then you can
have a fruitful interaction
so you don't need to give up your
viewpoints or your mental positions
but not be totally identified with it so
that anybody who questions it becomes
your enemy
it's so interesting because obviously
you're not a political beast
but what you're saying here is so
applicable to everything that everyone's
fighting about
sort of politically these days but i
want to ask you one one other thing
about the state of the world before we
move into a little bit of the technology
part of this and the off the grid sense
which is that i think you know a bit
about my story i used to consider myself
an atheist
for probably most of my adult life and i
don't anymore for probably about four or
five years i would say
i would say i'm more of a believer now
than i've ever been in my adult life
and i think that is connected to my
ability to sort of
stay sane within a very polarized
political time and as someone that puts
their opinions out there
and i i wonder what you think about that
just sort of where what the state of
belief is
at the moment you know when we factor in
this last year and a half
and lockdowns and fearfulness of a
disease and
you know if i walk outside this might
happen and and so on
uh yes it's uh the
belief really should lead to
a little bit of an uh
deeper realization belief alone
is fine is to be to believe that that
your life has a purpose
is good that there is a greater purpose
to life than just your personal life and
somehow your personal life leads to
needs to be in alignment with a greater
purpose that pervades the universe
there is an an intelligence
that is transcendent to a
sense-perceived reality that is beyond
that
a an intelligence that
manifests itself in this world
but is also beyond this world now
whether we call that
vast inconceivable intelligence
god or the divine or
no name at all uh doesn't really matter
so it's good to to believe that
that is there and then the next step is
to have a little bit of a
as an experience to experience
that which lies beyond the world of
form which has physical forms and even
mental forms and that which lies beyond
the world of form
is this transcendent dimension
that humans can sense
within themselves in it sounds perhaps a
little abstract right now
but you can sense it um
for example in between two thoughts
when you are one thought comes to an end
and there's a moment of clear awareness
you're just you're looking around
sometimes happens when you're out in
nature
you're able to stop thinking for a
moment but you don't lose consciousness
there's still an awareness there and you
perceive it perceive
everything against this background of
awareness
that is the light of consciousness that
is this is why
against this connected with religion
jesus said
to his disciples you are the light of
the world
he's talking to everybody when he said
that you are
now this doesn't mean you're a very
special human being you're more special
than others
because the people he talked to were not
special
on a worldly level they were not vips
they were simple people but he said you
are the light of the world in another
gospel he said it about himself he said
i am the light of the world so both
statements he said
now what what does that mean if you are
the light of the world
you the light in you is the
consciousness
the consciousness with which with the
world
is perceived the consciousness without
which no sense perception would be
possible the consciousness without which
no thought would be
would be possible so you are this
light of consciousness and to sense
yourself as a consciousness that is
far more vast than the
personality which consists of thought
movement to sense yourself for a moment
fence that inner stillness
but not go to sleep no very alert sense
that inner stillness
then you can sense the dimension the
inner dimension that is
deeper than the personality and that is
the light of the world
that emanates we're going a bit deep now
but let's do it yeah
let's do it that is the light of the
world the light of consciousness
that emanates from the transcendent
source of all life so to me
god is the transcendent source of all
lives
god does not have a location in space or
time
god transcends space and time but god
it's a bit like the sun
in the sense perceived world the sun
emanates
life it animates light which is life
continuously
it emanates now let's imagine that you
are the array of sunlight
and suddenly you realize
that that you that who you who are what
you are
emanates from the sun before you didn't
know it because you thought you were
a disconnected ray just a little or
little spark disconnected
and and then you become still for a
moment and you sense that connectedness
to something much deeper than the person
so you just
a moment of stillness in one of the
psalms in the old testament it says
be still and know that i am
god you can only know god in the
stillness when you
when you become still then suddenly to
go back to the analogy
the ray of sunlight realizes its
connectedness
and oneness with the sun
and some mystics who discovered that in
themselves
suddenly said i am god that's not
advisable to do and then usually people
didn't
like that so because the ray of sunlight
yes it's eternally connected it's an
emanation of the sun
but it's not the sun you are an
emanation or your consciousness is an
emanation
of the godhead or god
but you are not god but you are
connected you are one with god and you
are not
seemingly paradoxical or contradictory
statements
so just the belief is good
and then the belief can lead to
something a little deeper than just the
belief so you
and then you can rest in that sense of
connectedness to something
that transcends the personality you rest
in that and that is what is called
that i to me that is the true meaning of
faith faith to me is not just an
ideological belief
that this is the case or or the belief
that a certain
story from the past actually happened
faith is trust and the trust comes with
the realization that there's more to you
than just the personality the person the
and this
to be rooted in this trust is inner
peace
and then you can breathe smoke clearly
you can be
there are people who are extremely
knowledgeable about spirituality and
everything else
but they have never gone that little
step
further from from recognizing the truth
on an intellectual level which is good
to going a little bit further and
realize
the truth experientially
in their own lives and that frees them
from
fear and anxiety that's a it's a
wonderful
liberation to realize that maybe not
continuously but you have
more and more you realize there is more
to you
than meets the eye so to speak that you
are not
the physical body you are not your mind
even
there's an invisible presence that is
the essence of who you are
and it's vital for humans to realize
that
i believe that's the next step now that
old-fashioned religions uh in
many countries are beginning to
disappear
the old region but this in a way there's
the i can see you see why many humans
cannot believe these stories anymore
but we have to be very careful that the
what is the expression
the baby throw out the baby with the
bath water
because there's something extremely
valuable there still
this is why i often refer back to that
it just needs to be
more than an ideology it's we need to
take one step further into that
realization
so this is a we could talk about this
for a long time but
i don't know whether this will help
anybody but i hope so no i
well first off of course it's going to
help people but really you're describing
my own personal journey almost to a t
and you're actually also describing why
this will be my fifth year doing this
off the grid august
situation because it was on the first
one where i was sitting on a beach and
david
kept saying to me for days why aren't
you reading a book why aren't you're
just sitting and staring at the ocean
and i said that that's actually what i
need right now
and it was truly in that moment when the
thought popped into my mind
that i'm not an atheist and i would say
in the in the five years since then have
been the most
sort of rewarding and enriching and full
years that i've had on this planet so i
actually so i wonder could
to connect that to what i'm doing with
this month
um i i suppose someone like you kind of
kind of dig something like this the idea
that someone could put down the devices
and i wonder what what do you think just
in general about a world
that is so obsessively connected to
other people's thoughts
all day long yes that's good so um
the over this um excessive
identification with thinking and
overthinking ex
excessive thinking had been there for a
long time long before we came up with
these
devices but these devices
amplify the human tendency to
to engage or indulge in excessive
thinking
and problem making thinking rather than
constructive thinking
focused thinking uh so
the what you are doing uh is
very very helpful because you are
basically
having a period of uh we could call it
decluttering your mind
you declutter your mind and this is
necessary because
our mind most people's minds have never
been as
cluttered as they are now
uh glutton means there's a continuous
input
of stuff that comes in through the
devices
the messages come in
facebook posts tweets
and continuously the devices demand your
attention
and say this is important and a lot of
it is not
important but as we all know
there's an addictive quality to it it
draws
your attention to it and then every time
it draws your attention
you add to the clutter of your mind a
lot of not is not constructive
a lot of it is just random people often
see people
they get out their phones and they do
this random scrolling i can see it's
random there's nothing
specific but they think they have to do
it because everybody else is doing it
around them
wherever you are these days people are
engaging with this
and they're continuously taking in
thoughts from others
and as we said before some of these
thoughts
may be toxic and they may easily become
lodged in your mind
so to declutter is extremely important
and you can see if you even just
not using a device for a day for many
people is very very hard uh
and some think they can do it but they
can't so they are truly
addicted um
now when you when you when you declutter
your mind
first of all you put down your phone you
don't use it
not everybody can do it for whole months
like you of course
i recommend to everybody to have certain
periods of time when they
uh do not engage so for example
in your bedroom might be a good place to
chart for not engaging with any device
certain periods of time when you go out
into nature
be there rather than carry that thing
and every time it makes a noise you
still look up and you're still
even while you're surrounded by beauty
and aliveness
you're still engaging with this or
everything that you are looking at is an
opportunity for an instagram post and
you're just looking
look i'm here now me here
me there and then he sent it out
to so you never again
uh become completely trapped in
in the mind more than more than
even with these devices i'm very
concerned about youngsters these days
who grow up with them
the first perhaps is the first
generation i don't know the first iphone
was maybe 12
13 years ago something like that and
these
many youngsters for many youngsters the
virtual
reality is more important to them
than others and this is a very dangerous
development
the they lose the ability to relate
to other humans they spend several hours
per day
on devices whereas before they would go
out
running around outside playing their
games
uh creative coming up with new games
creative
activities relating to nature climbing
up
trees yes it's a little bit of risky you
might fall down but
again our society is obsessed with
safety and security but anyway let's not
go there right now
so um i'm very concerned
if
it's not inconceivable that it could
have such a detrimental
effect on consciousness that within
two generations it could lead to
the breakdown of civilization because
humans would no longer be able to
creatively think focus on a specific
problem
for long enough to find a solution uh
connect
with a deeper intelligence that is
necessary to
to do anything creative in this world to
give attention to something for a
certain period of time
rather than have a short attention
periods periods you can't
focus on anything for very long how can
you solve a problem
if you can cannot look at it face it and
then
become still for a moment activate your
deeper intelligence
and then see what the solution might be
so if
we lose the ability you know that uh
it's parents responsibility to limit
their children's time with these devices
and
i would so that periodically take them
out into nature without these things
so that they don't lose their ability to
connect with nature
how it's so important to connect with
nature
to because they you find sanity there
that was my saving thing when i was a
child i would get on my bike i was very
unhappy in my home environment
this was very very dysfunctional
my parents couldn't help it they were
just in the grip of dysfunction
as and their parents had been in the
grip of dysfunction and so i would get
to my bike go out into nature
like a 15-minute bike ride not
magnificent fantastic nature just
normal fields groves of trees
and there i would suddenly get off my
bike and say
ah i didn't have any devices to distract
me if there weren't any
i would actually be there and look
and i would often say to myself this
will always be here
i didn't know what that meant i i i
could feel that nature was more
important than the man-made world the
human-made world
the human-made world for me was a very
unhappy one
and the the natural world was where i
found
liberation whenever i went there
but if i had these phones i would have
carried that with me and probably
no longer be able to really relate to it
you'll be happy to know that by the time
we air this i will probably be sitting
in a tree house on in a rain forest
doing exactly this i mean this is
exactly why i wanted to talk to you
before i went off the grid but but you
mentioned something that i thought was
really interesting which is that it's
not
it's not just that we're being inundated
with other people's thoughts
but that we're never giving ourself the
space
the moments where in the old days if you
said you were going to meet your friend
at a restaurant well if you went to the
restaurant first
and they weren't there you might have to
sit for a few moments you might have to
perhaps talk to somebody else but you
might have to just stand
and look around and think and see people
where now we don't do that at all what
do we all immediately do
so it's it's really about creating that
space in many ways is more important
than inoculating or immunizing the
thoughts that's
that's almost the obvious one it's it's
the other piece
exactly that's very important and that
is something
that anybody can do to create that space
uh the it's very true what you say
almost nowhere do you see people uh
where wherever people congregated
airports
cafes benches park benches wherever they
are
most of them are engaged with their
devices it's incredible
so to consciously decide not to engage
whenever for example you're waiting for
something or someone and a lot of the
time we are waiting for things in this
world
you're waiting for somebody as you set
an example
for friend to arrive and you're sitting
there why do you need to engage why can
you
just be contemplate the world look
around
and be and enjoy being in the moment
in this moment and those are the states
where creative insights often arise if
you don't give yourself space
it's very unlikely that any creative
realizations
ideas insights realizations will
will arise in you because your to your
mind is too cluttered
so if you give yourself space it's more
likely that
you will become more creative as a human
being because that's where these things
without space good new ideas
insights and realizations don't arise
there's no room for them to arise so
give yourself
a wonderful example you're waiting for
somebody just be there
unless there's actually something to
communicate maybe
he he's texting he says i'll be five
minutes late
fine okay and then you put it away
uh i often recommend any time you're
waiting
just be conscious of yourself
in the present moment elevators even
you you push press the button elevator
and you're waiting
why do you need to get out your phone
into for thought
half a minute or one minute why why you
don't need
just be breathe consciously give yours
have a little bit of inner space inner
space
the loss of inner space is a terrible
loss
and that is the opposite of clutter
make sure that that you become aware of
this inner
inner space where there's no clutter
there's just a lovely
aware presence with you contemplate the
world around you
you aware perhaps that you're breathing
you're aware
even perhaps that your body is alive you
can sense that your body is alive
in a space without spaciousness
your life is very unsatisfying the most
satisfying thing in life is
inner spaciousness and many humans
don't have that anymore and we all we
all know that it's true if we if we
would take that moment to think about it
what you're describing we all know is
true you know
in the years that i've done this when i
come back in september i always notice i
have a certain
force field where i'm able to put the
device down more i'm able to pay less
attention
but then of course you know the news
starts again or there's an election or
something happened
and then it gets sort of smaller and
smaller but i'm wondering as
as you're discussing this how much of
this is just that we have to battle what
our own nature
is in a way that we have to battle what
the ego is so for example if you go to a
concert
for a musician or a band that you love
instead of just
being there and just being there we're
all doing we're all taking the video
we're all taking the pictures because we
want the likes and all that
and that we're actually sort of
denigrating the thing that
gives us that transcendent experience
yes so we're battling something within
ourselves
yes it's a certain conditioned patterns
that we
kind of collectively inherit where it's
we were born into this world and we
at an early age we already become
conditioned
by these collective patterns that up
part
some belong to our family and background
some belong to
the general culture that we grow up in
so we become conditioned
and to become aware of one's own
conditioning and again the key word is
aware
if you become aware of your conditioning
you're no longer totally in the grip of
your conditioning
it may still operate yes but you're not
this
you have one foot out in one foot in the
conditioning if you are aware
and the example you gave is also
interesting because
whenever people see something they have
the thing is there they need to um
videotape video age or fake for taking
for selfies or snapshots so many people
have lost the ability to experience
something
because everything that they that arises
is looked at as a possibility for
a photo or or video and everything is
experienced to the screen of when people
go on vacation often you can see that
they walk around maybe the most
magnificent place and instead of
experiencing it fully they experience it
through this and perhaps the idea is
when i get home and i look at this then
i'll be able to experience it fully when
and either
and it never it never works that way it
never works that way we're trying to
hold on to something that we're not
fully grasping in the first place yes
and of course it's obviously it's nice
sometimes to be able to
to film something it's sometimes nice
i sometimes one of my favorite subjects
for
taking for photos is the sky i love the
sky
and the difference the clouds and the
different uh
formations i have hundreds of photos of
the sky that i take on my phone
but i'm not absorbed by it i look at the
sky maybe for
five minutes i enjoy the beauty of it
and then i get out my phone and i think
wow this is so wonderful
and that's fine but i'm
i'm not treating it as an opportu
a photo opportunity or a selfie
opportunity
not that there's anything wrong with
occasional selfies
but if the whole thing takes over your
life
then that's that is dreadful right i
have a feeling i wouldn't see you
wandering down the street taking selfies
with the with the clouds as the less
important part i always
say that the first you know the myth of
the ancient greek mystery of narcissus
the man
this is where the term narcissism comes
from which is a narcissism being an
extreme form of ego
so narcissus was a beautiful young man
uh
he was very happy and one day he was
walking
and he saw a pool of water this of
course the time there were not any
mirrors at that time
in a pool of water he saw his own
reflection
and the story goes says he fell in love
with his own reflection
what is better way of putting it is he
became obsessed with his own reflection
and from then on he became very unhappy
and his life
didn't go well after that we don't know
you don't need to go into what happened
to him but it wasn't good
now this is a a symbolic way of
expressing what happened to human
consciousness when the ego developed
the ego is an is an image of who you are
in your mind
it's a self-image and when
narcissus saw himself
the myth is a symbolic expression of
what happened to human consciousness
as the ego developed as as a
then you'd suddenly have an image of who
you are
i call it the first the first selfie
ever was when i see
his reflection in the in the mirror in
the pool of water
and this also the
living through a persona
which persona is where the word person
comes from and the
latin word persona actually means mask
living through a mental image of who you
are and projecting this mental image
that was already there before we came up
with all these devices
but now it's become amplified because
many especially many young people
they live through facebook and instagram
and they create an image for themselves
that they project out into the world
and it totally
bears little resemblance to who they
actually are
now now there's the added thing they can
use
food filters and photoshop everybody can
look beautiful
even i could look beautiful with a
little bit that filter
and often they you wouldn't recognize
these
these if you saw them in the street
totally
distorted but they live through it it
becomes
more important to them than their own
being
and this is a it's a it's a ultimately
it makes humans very unhappy
to live well i realized i mean that in
many ways is why i wanted to start doing
this because i realized as someone that
talks to the camera and people say nice
things to me and
you know my i get traction on twitter
and all those things i felt that i was
not i wasn't trying to control it but
but it was becoming sort of bigger than
me which is why i want to do this so i
so actually
only want to ask you one more thing
because i want to be respectful of your
time but for
for most of my audience what i sense
people are going through right now is
they're they're
deeply worried that the world that
they knew is disappearing at a very
rapid rate that you sort of hinted at
something like that at the beginning
that the things that they cared about
about freedom and
and the individual that these things are
going away and it's being amplified by
social media
and bad political leaders and everything
else what would you say is a way
to battle it without becoming consumed
by it that's that's what i try to do on
my show all the time i always try to do
it with a little bit of a smile and a
little
sense of humor because i don't want
people to be crazy but i'm obviously not
perfect at this
what would you say to the average person
that wants to be aware they want to be
engaged in current events and politics
but also don't want to give their life
to it so at the expense of everything
else that you've discussed here
yes do everything with awareness so that
uh
instead of being reactive let's see you
see somebody's posting something
and you feel you want to reply
don't be reactive and attack somebody
that you don't even have never
have never even met and don't equate
somebody's perhaps erroneous
opinion with who they actually are
i think it's maybe if if you feel called
upon to do that
it may be good to point out what
you regard as irrational statements that
are irrational
point out viewpoints that you think are
toxic without attacking the human being
that has these viewpoints you can attack
opinions and viewpoints
or show it that you would show them that
they are
they are erroneous without making the
people who have them
into absolute evil beings
the to separate the what happens on the
level of mind
uh from the human being underneath it's
easier to do that in
when you're actually meeting a human
being then it it's you can because you
can see
there's the there's the i sometimes call
it
the human and the being everybody is a
human being the human
is the conditioned mind
the personality the conditioned entity
is a human
and the being is the the consciousness
that's beyond that
that's the deeper being that's the the
the one could say the the true human
that's the child of god
every human is a child of god but the
overlay may be very very dense of
conditioning that's the human level
it's easier not to lose sight of the
being dimension in another human when
you
see them face to face and you perhaps
it's you can still sense it
but when you're only relating to
abstract
uh words often on the screen
then you confuse what's produced by the
human
level with who
with being the you lose sight of being
their being completely
uh so uh
uh what do you there's an absurd
statement that you read
and you feel you want to clarify that
it's perfectly fine to do that if you
feel called upon to do it if you think
it has a purpose to do that sometimes it
might sometimes
we might not without making the person
who has that opinion
into an enemy although he or she will
try to make you into an enemy
of course don't in other words don't
contribute to the
insanity bring sanity into this world
do not allow the insanity to pull you in
because that that can easily happen
it pulls you in and then the then you
the monster that you in other words
remember who said it
um when you fight games just be careful
that you don't become a monster
um or when you need to set when you look
into the abyss
then the the the abyss also looks into
you or something like that
so that it's not only the case uh
so i think to to
bear in mind to bring sanity into this
world
is your job to bring um
to bring sanity into a world that in
many ways
is go going in the opposite direction
it's becoming more and more crazy
so it's doubly important for you to
represent to embody the sanity
and always be aware of the gravitational
pull
of craziness which is there all around
you
and the gravitational pull the the
the reactivity that comes you don't need
that
don't give yourself a moment when you
feel um
reactive before you post anything
give yourself a few minutes to calm down
become present and then see what useful
contribution
you could make to this particular
discussion or what it may be
so who said it i don't remember the
famous
phrase be the change that you want to
see in this world
maybe it was nelson mandela i don't
remember who is quite who said it but
doesn't matter
uh be the so if you want more sanity
in this world and if you if you see that
there's a lot of insanity
in this world then it's your job
not to become part of the insanity
you cannot fight insanity with more
insanity
so be aware be present
be conscious and don't be totally
identified with your mental positions
but express them clearly but realize who
you
are is far deeper than your mental
positions they are relatively important
but not absolutely important one thing
that's absolutely important is your
being
there's a human and there's a being you
are both
and you're you can exist in both
dimensions
consciously in the being and
and be active on the human level without
losing yourself on the human level which
is the mind
which is the world which is the internet
that's all the human level
so be a real human being so that the
two dimensions are active in you
well eckhart uh you know it's funny i i
asked you to explain it for my audience
and i know you were talking directly to
them there but i genuinely felt like you
were talking directly to me and that's
exactly why
i do this off the grid for 30 days and i
give you my word that i will be trying
to connect my human and my being
and uh i you what what a great way
to to leave for me so i thank you so
much
and i promise you that i'm going to
incorporate that even further
when i get back in the fall right and
have a wonderful time on your retreat
thank you my friend thank you if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about spirituality instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
spirituality playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell